is it true that you got a tattoo what's
that story when when you we were first
tattoo oh my very first tattoo so I yeah
so I had um I had this best friend when
I was younger of course which they were
they fun they were very fun and I was
very introverted and she had wanted this
tattoo for a long long time meaning we
were both 14 and so she'd been hyper
fixating on it for a couple months and I
knew about this but she was so scared of
the pain
um that me little like introverted
homeschool no friends chicken owning
chicken owning Midwest yeah I almost
said Midwest specific Northwest girl
um I volunteered as tribute to like go
first I was like okay okay I'll get a
tattoo first and I'll tell you if it's
really painful and
and and we did it it was my first tattoo
ever it was like a Gateway don't start
you won't by the way I know look at her
beautiful hand I know I'm I'm covered
it's so bad